colombia es el país más desigual en
materia de ingresos en américa latina y
el caribe según el banco mundial en
diciembre de 2021 el desempleo llegaba
casi al 11% y la pobreza extrema supera
el 6% de acuerdo con la cepal tras dos
años de pandemia hay una economía
golpeada los colombianos asisten a las
urnas para elegir al sucesor de guandul
quien llegó a la presidencia por el
partido de derecha centro democrático
actualmente la desaprobación del
mandatario ronda el 73% es muy difícil
que la pandemia pero también tuvo
enormes oportunidades de convocar a la
unión del país y no lo supo hacer y
sobre todo en lo que sería la inversión
porque derecha más fuerte deja al
país
con un riesgo de explosión de violencia
o no un riesgo una realidad de explosión
de violencia muy grave creo que durante
el gobierno duques por primera vez en
los últimos yo diría
20 años
pronto un poco más que la tasa de
homicidio vuelve a crecer así la derecha
llega dividida a los comicios con una
coalición de varios precandidatos
presidenciales llamada equipo por
colombia pero el centro democrático el
partido de gobierno y el principal
referente de la derecha en el país
presenta a su candidato óscar iván
zuluaga por separado realmente el mismo
hecho de que el equipo colombia haya
querido el tratado de organizarse por
fuera del uribismo sin el uribismo y
rechazando incluso su participación pues
muestra hasta qué punto la la herencia
del gobierno de un presidente del centro
democrático es muy difícil de asumir en
estas elecciones la izquierda en cambio
llega unida y con fuerza con sus
precandidatos agrupados en el llamado
pacto histórico dominado por la figura
de gustavo petro el principal líder
opositor votado es una figura muy
popular pero muy impopular y es muy
impopular porque los dos argumentos
contra la izquierda pero los encarna
petro le ha apostado a la paz de manera
irreprochable pero es un antiguo
guerrillero entonces puedes sacar la
cosa
algunas de las propuestas de petro son
descalificadas así es con buenos
argumentos como propuestas riesgosas
colombia es un país en el que la
izquierda nunca ha gobernado no obstante
algunos factores han cambiado el
panorama uno de ellos es el estallido
social de 2021 yo creo que las
movilizaciones o una de las
características que tuvieron las
movilizaciones es a los jóvenes si les
interesa la punta no los jóvenes si
están preocupados por el devenir de un
país y los analistas y malos
especialistas de marketing político que
dicen si los jóvenes salen a votar es de
votos para el partido pese a la
fortaleza con la que llega a la
izquierda la elección dista de ser claro
que pueda lograr una mayoría en el
congreso y aún más difícil que llegue a
la presidencia en un país cuyos
políticos de centroderecha han mostrado
una gran capacidad de unión para
derrotarla